[تصفيق]
تحت شعار من الامكانات الى الازدهار بدات
في الدوحه اعمال مؤتمر الامم المتحده
للبلدان الاقلين نموا المؤتمر المعني بس
46 دوله يعقد كل عشر سنوات لكنه اجل مرتين
بسبب جائحه كورونا خلال افتتاح المؤتمر
دعى امير قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني
الى سرعه اغاثه في سوريا وحذر من استخدام
المساعدات لاغراض سياسيه كما شدد على دعم
جهود تركيا لتجاوز الكارثه واعلن امير قطر
تقديم مساهمه بقيمه 60 مليون دولار لدعم
عمليه التنميه في البلدان الاقل نموا
وتعزيز قدرتها على الصمود
وانطلاقا من التزام دوله قطر الثابت تجاه
دعمه عمليه التنميه لاقل البلدان نموا
اعلنوا عن تقديم مساهمه ماليه باجمال ستين
مليون دولار امريكي يخصص منها عشره مليون
دولار لدعم تنفيذ انشطه برنامج عمل الدوحه
من جهته دعا الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو الدول المتقدمه للايفاء
بالتزاماتها في مساعده البلدان الاقل نموا
واعلن عن برنامج عمل الدوحه لدعم هذه
البلدان وهو التزام مدته عشر سنوات لتعزيز
شركات بين البلدان الاقل نموا والبلدان
المتقدمه وكذلك القطاع الخاص والمجتمع
المدني
هو دليل عملي لمعالجه كل هذه القضايا
ويحتوي على اهداف ونتائج ملموسه وادعو
شركاءنا في التنميه الى دعم تنفيذ هذه
النتائج وتحقيق اهداف برنامج عمل الدوحه
المؤتمر يدعو من خلال برامجه الى احياء
شعار صفر فقر في العالم الذي يحتاج الى
تضافر الجهود الدوليه لمواجهه اثار الحروب
والتغيرات المناخيه وازمه الطاقه وغيرها
من التداعيات على البلدان الاقل نموا
استضافه الدوحه لمؤتمر الامم المتحده
الخامس المعني بالبلدان الاقل نموا بعد
انقطاع دام سنوات تمثل خريطه طريق للمجتمع
الدولي لمساعده هذه الدول في تحقيق
التعافي من الازمات التي تعيشها وتسريع
تقدمها في مختلف المجالات
صار رشيد الجزيره الدوحه